let that sink in that's what Elon
tweeted after marching into Twitter's
headquarters carrying an actual sink
after months of back and forth Elon
finally bought Twitter for 44 billion
dollars and as soon as he got control of
Twitter he began cleaning house if we're
gonna turn this company around we gotta
start cutting the crust off this
sandwich Elon was ruthless the CEO the
Chief Financial Officer the company's
top lawyer they were all fired just like
that quickly getting escorted out of
Twitter San Francisco headquarters sure
they'll received tens of millions of
dollars in Severance packages but their
reign is finally over and now it's time
for him to fire Twitter's entitled
employees see Twitter is a horrible
business that barely makes any money a
horrible business that Elon had to
borrow 13 billion dollars to be able to
buy that means Elon is gonna have to pay
a billion dollars every year in just
interest for that loan that means Elon
is on the clock if he doesn't turn
around Twitter fast he is going to get
buried and guess what's the easiest way
for him to cut costs that's right
Twitter's employees Twitter has over
7500 employees that get paid hundreds of
thousands of dollars each for an app
that lets you write 280 characters of
text so yeah the majority of these
employees are completely useless and
should be fired after the deal closed
Elon tweeted out the bird has been freed
but if the bird doesn't quickly learn
how to fly It's Gonna Come crashing down
this is the Hostile takeover of Twitter
[Music]
if you're watching this channel you're
probably an ambitious person and one of
the best ways to make yourself look more
impressive in high status is by learning
a new language just think about how much
someone's eyes will light up when you
say a simple phrase in their native
tongue maybe this person is someone
you're trying to do business with or
maybe it's a girl you're trying to
impress I've done it a bunch of times
and I can assure you it's really worth
the effort
and plus learning a language is now
easier than ever thanks to Babel one of
the top language learning apps in the
world simply download the app choose the
language you want to learn I chose
Russian for myself and then boom within
a few minutes of their interactive
lessons you'll find yourself knowing a
bunch of practical words and phrases
that you actually need to use and what I
love about Babel is that it gives you
feedback on your pronunciation on the
spot thanks to their top tier speech
recognition tech there are no ads or
other annoying things that other apps
have and you learn all of this through
quick 10 minute interactive lessons that
you can squeeze into your schedule at
any time and they're really fun over 10
million people purchase a babble
subscription and on top of that Babel
Has Been empirically proven by academics
from places like Yale University to help
you start speaking a new language in
just three weeks yes you've heard that
right less than a month that's why
they're able to offer a 20-day
money-back guarantee so what language
are you gonna learn choose from 14
different languages to learn from right
now with an extra 60 off your
subscription by clicking the link below
so pause the video and click the link
below for 60 off your battle
subscription now thanks to Babel for
sponsoring this video
people assume that just because Twitter
is a huge social network where hundreds
of millions of users they must be
insanely profitable but in reality
Twitter has not thrown a profit for 8
out of the last 10 years instead they
actively lose a bunch of money every
year in 2020 Twitter lost over 1.1
billion dollars a year later they lost
220 million dollars compare Twitter to
other tech jobs like Facebook and Google
and you see a stark difference go on
Facebook or in sailing great businesses
they actually make money every year how
about that and each year they make more
money than the last while Twitter well
take a look for yourself that's because
when you're browsing Facebook or
Instagram or Google or YouTube you are
constantly bombarded with ads while
Twitter you hardly see any ads on there
so how do they make money well as you
can see they don't and yet somehow
Twitter has over 7 500 employees for a
text editor and these employees are
spoiled rotten
a quick Google search online and you'll
discover that Twitter's employees get
paid hundreds of thousands of dollars
most get paid a minimum of around 150
000 per year with some getting paid well
over three hundred thousand dollars per
year now that is not a bad thing you
should pay your employees a lot if
they're making you a lot of money or if
they're doing really complex work but
Twitter's employees aren't making
Twitter a lot of money in fact any
reasonable business person will be able
to tell you that they're actively
siphoning Twitter of all their profits
and again all of this is so that users
can type 280 characters of texts but
don't take our word for it some Twitter
employees have been gracious enough to
give us a glimpse into the very
difficult day in the life of working on
Twitter iced matcha to kick off your
stressful day cozy log cabin areas to
relax foosball tables meditation and
yoga rooms red wine on tap to get the
juices flowing now one would think that
if you were in the shoes of an overpaid
underwork Twitter employee you might be
thinking to yourself man I don't know
how sustainable this is for them to keep
paying us these insane salaries and
benefits while they're losing money
every year I should be grateful that
they haven't fired me yet but sadly this
is not the case
[Music]
when rumors started flying around that
Elon was gonna make some massive layoffs
the Twitter workers wrote a collective
letter to Elon expressing some of their
concerns and demands and what did
Twitter employees have to say about
running the company into the ground
while taking fat salaries that firing
them with her Twitter's ability to serve
the public conversation because they've
been doing that so well lately
that following us is reckless that it
will undermine our users trust in the
platform because people definitely trust
Twitter as a platform that it's worker
intimidation that we're uplifting
independent journalism in Ukraine and
Iran that we Empower social movements
that matter around the world and we must
preserve the Integrity of our platform
at all costs so we demand protection
their severance pay when you actually do
fire us we demand to be treated with
dignity that we will not be treated like
puns in a game played by billionaires
you would think this letter came from
Sweatshop workers or coal miners but no
these demands came from entitled Tech
workers making six figures sipping on
wine while Banning you for having a
different opinion while at the same time
acting like they're both the victim and
the hero
now you may be wondering but how are
companies like this even able to stay in
business while losing so much money
every year to understand that you have
to understand the game that so-called
tech companies play as long as you can
maintain the image of a revolutionary
tech company that is set to change the
world investors will throw money at you
because investors want to find that
needle in a haystack tech company that
will 100x a thousand extra money and the
only companies that can do that are
so-called tech companies that really do
end up changing the world when in
reality most of these tech companies are
neither Tech nor a company they're
nothing more than a super basic app with
a pretty design that loses money that's
why tech companies are obsessed with
talents we gotta hire the absolute best
talent and pay them the best most
competitive salaries tech companies have
to have overpaid workers and a lot of
them Twitter has to have 7 500 employees
for their basic text editor or else they
won't be able to maintain the facade if
they don't have a big team investors
will think to themselves how is this
company going to change the world and
provide me mean what else has returns if
they don't even have a giant team of the
smartest brightest Minds on payroll as
Peter Thiel says we wanted flying cars
instead we got 140 characters and we
cover all this excessively in our
Silicon Valley Posse scheme video if you
want to learn more and the executives at
Twitter were profiting handsomely from
this facade that is P Twitter was at 77
a share while the executives the CEO
made over 30 million dollars in 2021 the
Chief Financial Officer he made nearly
19 million dollars the chief legal
officer made nearly 17 million dollars
they had no incentive to cut costs and
actually run a functioning company so
they didn't these were the same people
Elon fired as soon as he took control
you're fired get the hell out of here
come on and all of this was sustainable
for the last decade or so because of the
money printer
money was flying off the shelves money
was super easy and cheap to borrow
returns were psychotic
until they weren't
until the American money printer started
going in reverse and raising interest
rates all of a sudden now you actually
have to have a functioning company to
stay afloat annoying right
but now that Elon Musk has taken over
and has taken the company privates he
actually has an incentive to turn a
profit a billion dollars worth of
interest payments a year of an incentive
to turn a profits so after firing the
executives and the Annoying employees
who were bashing him he filled the
employee parking lot with Teslas Tesla
is owned by his closest confidants
including devices who worked with Elon
during the PayPal days and 50 of elon's
top Engineers product managers and
leaders from his other companies like
Tesla SpaceX and the boring company or
collectively called elon's goons by some
employees and their job is simple figure
out who to Fire and how to make Twitter
more money while making it a better
platform Twitter Engineers have already
been asked to print out a bunch of code
that they've written so that they can be
interrogated Twitter managers are being
evaluated for their jobs so current
employees are literally shaking right
now they're forming private group chats
to comfort each other some of them are
half joking about how they're constantly
refreshing their inbox just waiting for
the termination email and on top of
layoffs Elon has some major changes he's
planning to make to the Twitter app
itself like making verified Twitter
users pay 20 a month to stay verified or
maybe even bringing back Vine or some
kind of tick tock Style video element to
Twitter but by far the easiest way for
Elon to make more money is just by
firing useless employees and you're
fired the average Twitter worker is
making about 150 000 a year according to
Glassdoor so if all Elon did was fire 3
300 employees which would be 44 of
Twitter's Workforce he would save around
half a billion dollars every year which
is already half of his interest payments
which again an app that lets you write
280 characters a text can probably
survive with just a mere 4 200 employees
knowing Elon he's probably got some
crazy ideas in store for Twitter but
we'll just have to wait and see and you
can bet that if anything big happens
we'll cover it on this channel so
subscribe to find out what happens next
Twitter Tick Tock and meta are by far
the worst at censorship YouTube is by
far the most reasonable they at least
try but YouTube is still far from
perfect they might not outright ban you
for talking about things like the Middle
East every Jeff scene or vaccines but
they will assure them monetize your
video and age restrict it which stops
the algorithm from promoting it this
prevents us from covering really
important topics that we think should be
covered like China's Force organ
harvesting where Chinese hospitals are
able to sell westerners juicy succulent
organs on demand in a matter of weeks
instead of waiting years on a western
transplant waiting list how are they
able to offer such an expedited service
you may ask because they kill transplant
donors on demand and all these donors
happen to be dissonance Christians
Muslims activists politicians religious
Scholars counter-revolutionary elements
that promote disgusting things like
democracy or religious freedom and this
business brings in big money we're
talking 62 000 for a kidney thirty
thousand dollars for an eye a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars for a liver
three hundred thousand dollars for a
pair of lungs however we have to stop
going over this right now before we get
to monetized or age restricted but if
you want to watch the full private
documentary on this and many other
topics too controversial for YouTube
scroll down and click that join button
below this YouTube membership came out
of this need to cover important topics
that wouldn't fly on YouTube it's where
we post a new private documentary every
month never to be released publicly like
this one on Force organ harvesting which
is by far our most disturbing one yet or
other ones on the business of vaccines
the roots of Middle Eastern Terror the
man that didn't kill himself and much
more that you'll get instant access to
the goal of this membership is to teach
you how the world really works unlike
College while being astronomically
cheaper than College just five bucks a
month with a 30-day refund policy unlike
most YouTube memberships meaning that if
you join for the first time and you
don't think it's worth it email us and
we'll refund you your money so scroll
down and click that join button to watch
now
foreign